one of the most famous scientists in
American history is finally getting a
biopic for the first time but what's
competing for a movie of The Summer with
Christopher Nolan's Blockbuster Epic
the US government detonated the first
atomic bomb in New Mexico's hornada Del
muerto desert on July 16 1945. this
event the Trinity test changed the world
forever the U.S soon dropped two Atomic
weapons on Japan ending World War II in
the most destructive way possible it
also sparked a cold war arms race and
created a world run by nuclear
superpowers many people contributed to
the Manhattan Project the American
effort that led to the Trinity test but
one man truly bore responsibility for
the creation of the atomic bomb J Robert
Oppenheimer witnessing the first test of
History's deadliest weapon oppenheimer's
mind were called a scripture from the
bhagavad-gita
now I am become death
the destroyer of worlds
listen this incredibly controversial
invention has haunted oppenheimer's Life
and Legacy and it's surprising that no
one has made a biopic about such a
fascinating impactful man until now
nearly 80 years after atomic bombs
changed the course of human history
filmmaker Christopher Nolan will tell
the physicists story on the big screen
in a blockbuster that promises to be one
of 2023's best
Christopher Nolan's 12th film his first
for Universal also promises to be the
longest of his career speaking with
variety Oppenheimer actor Matt Damon
revealed the biopic runs about three
hours long although he assured everyone
that it's fast paced so when should we
expect to see the film light up the
Silver Screen Oppenheimer will debut on
July 21 2023 which promises to be a huge
day for cinephiles in a strange twist of
fate or perhaps a deliberate move
Oppenheimer will compete with one of the
most anticipated movies of the Year
Barbie which comes from Nolan's former
partners at Warner Brothers in the
battle between Mattel and the Manhattan
Project will Oppenheimer nuke the
competition or will it bomb big time
well as it's a Christopher Nolan movie
we trust that his dedicated fan base
will turn out strong for Oppenheimer
although we'll be interested to see how
this cinematic Showdown unfolds
Oppenheimer will be drawing inspiration
from a Pulitzer prize-winning Book
American Prometheus the Triumph and
tragedy of J Robert Oppenheimer by Kai
bird and Martin J Sherwin in his review
of the book for the guardian James
buckin wrote Oppenheimer was haunted by
Hiroshima and came to believe that the
Japanese were already essentially
defeated he despised the science at Los
Alamos Oppenheimer campaigned to push
the atomic Genie if not back into the
bottle at least into International
control we're assuming that's how the
movie will examine Oppenheimer as a
brilliant scientist filled with regret
lead actor Killian Murphy gave Credence
to this Theory when speaking with the
guardian in February 2022 I'm interested
in the man and what inventing the atomic
bomb does to the individual the
mechanics of it that's not really for me
I don't have the intellectual capacity
to understand them but these
contradictory characters are Fascinating
People identify with that because we all
walk around with these contradictory
ideas coexisting in our heads with such
a complicated person we can't wait to
see how the movie examines our
oppenheimer's story especially with an
actor of Murphy's caliber bringing this
historical figure to life
Oppenheimer has one of the most stacked
casts of any movie ever in the title
role is Irish actor Killian Murphy who's
been a longtime collaborator of
Christopher Nolans Oppenheimer will also
Mark a reunion between Murphy and his
quiet place part 2 co-star Emily Blunt
who will star as the scientist's wife
Kitty Oppenheimer
we're Jonas scientists ring their
families will never get the best next up
we've got Florence Pugh of mid-summer
and black widow Fame playing Communist
Party member Gene tatlock who has an
affair with Oppenheimer Matt Damon stars
as Leslie Groves the military figure who
served as the Director of the Manhattan
Project while Iron Man himself Robert
Downey Jr will reportedly play Lewis
Strauss a key player when it came to
developing nuclear weaponry and that's
not all uncut gems director Benny safdi
will portray the father of the hydrogen
bomb Edward Teller while the
oscar-winning Rami Malek will also play
a scientist involved with the Manhattan
Project David de smallchin from The Dark
Knight is reuniting here with
Christopher Nolan and he'll be joined by
the likes of Josh Harnett Jack Quaid and
Oscar winner Gary Oldman based on set
photos it even seems like Casey Affleck
is going to show up in this thing let's
see we've also got Alden aaronreich
Matthew Modine Kenneth Branagh and more
clearly Oppenheimer is shaping up to be
Nolan's most stacked film when it comes
to Raw acting Talent
Christopher Nolan is always pushing the
boundaries of his filmmaking further and
further needless to say Nolan isn't
slowing down with Oppenheimer from a
practical effects perspective it might
be his most ambitious movie to date
speaking with total film the director
elaborated a bit on a wild decision he
made for the movie saying I think
recreating the Trinity test without the
use of computer Graphics was a huge
challenge to take on from representing
Quantum Dynamics and quantum physics to
the Trinity test itself to recreating
with my team Los Alamos up on a Mesa in
New Mexico there were huge practical
challenges
one of Christopher Nolan's most frequent
collaborators is composer Hans Zimmer
who has scored seven of his feature
films from Batman Begins to Dunkirk but
for Nolan's 2020 spy Thriller tenet the
filmmaker chose Ludwig Goranson to
replace Zimmer after he opted to work on
Dune instead as it turned out gorinson
was the right choice lending his musical
talents to Nolan's action thriller to
create Melodies that sounded the same
whether they were played forward or
backward highlighting Nolan's
time-warping themes needless to say
we're excited about whatever gorinson
has cooked up for Oppenheimer aside from
his work with Nolan gorinson composed
the scores for 2018's Venom the first
two Creed films and both of Marvel
Studios Black Panther movies goranson's
work on the Mandalorian earned him two
Primetime Emmys Christopher Nolan held a
two-day casting call in Santa Fe and Los
Alamos before starting production on
Oppenheimer in January 2022. these were
the actual sites where Oppenheimer and
the Manhattan Project developed the
atomic bomb in the 1940s hundreds of
hopefuls attended eager to join Nolan's
latest picture production soon began in
New Mexico filming in Los Alamos
locations such as the historic Fuller
Lodge oppenheimer's home and other
surviving buildings like the women's
dorms and the United Church the
Oppenheimer cast and crew then moved to
the east coast filming at Princeton's
Institute for advanced study for a brief
period in April 2022 they also filmed
some scenes on the west coast in
California especially at the University
of California Berkeley by May 2022
Oppenheimer had completed production
after four months of rigorous shoots
world
will remember this day with the usual
difficulties of period filmmaking and
Nolan's added vision of recreating the
effects of an atomic bomb practically
Oppenheimer promises to be one of the
most ambitious films of 2023. in 2008's
the Dark Knight director Christopher
Nolan used 70 millimeter IMAX cameras to
give his pictures a distinct look and
feel though the second installment of
his The Dark Knight trilogy was the
first major motion picture to utilize
high-resolution IMAX cameras it wouldn't
be his last no matter if it's Wally
Fister or hoita van hoytama who has shot
every Nolan picture from Interstellar
onwards behind the camera the oturf
filmmaker has kept his signature
cinematic look no wonder he has been
tasked with helping design the next set
of IMAX cameras Oppenheimer follows
Nolan's style shooting on a combination
of imax's 65 millimeter and 65
millimeter large format cameras in
addition to using multiple IMAX bodies
this time around Nolan's latest feature
also utilized iMac his first attempt at
black and white photography the director
told total film we challenged the people
at Kodak and photochem to make this work
for us for the first time ever we were
able to shoot IMAX film in black and
white and the results were thrilling and
extraordinary as soon as hoida and I saw
the first tests come in we just knew
that this was a format that we were
immediately in love with
though writer director Christopher Nolan
reportedly used American Prometheus as
the basis for his latest picture some
wonder how accurate Oppenheimer will
actually be of course this isn't the
first time that Nolan has retold
historical events in a dramatic fashion
particularly those surrounding the
second world war with his 2017 feature
Dunkirk Nolan worked hard to stay true
to the historical narrative including
the small details though even that film
strayed from history on more than one
occasion with Oppenheimer our hopes are
high that it'll accurately articulate
the events of the Manhattan Project in
the inner turmoil of The Man Behind the
atomic bomb the theoretical physicist
was a chain smoker who died due to
complications regarding throat cancer
additionally the inclusion of Gene
tatlock a former girlfriend and Mistress
of oppenheimers only complicates things
further it makes it all a perfect
representation of the scientists
personal life Nolan told total film in
December of 2022 it's a story of immense
scope and scale and one of the most
challenging projects I've ever taken on
in terms of the scale of it and and in
terms of encountering the breadth of
oppenheimer's story
the Manhattan Project was a top secret
project in the United States during
World War II which led to the invention
of the atomic bomb along with support
from the United Kingdom and Canada the
project ran from 1942 until 1946 just
after the end of the war officially
codenamed the development of substitute
materials the Project's first
headquarters in Manhattan gave it its
famous nickname which eventually became
its official designation in fact the
Manhattan Project had access to a dozen
different project sites including one at
Berkeley California and the most famous
in Los Alamos New Mexico where much of
Oppenheimer takes place known as project
y the Los Alamos location was home to
Robert Oppenheimer he held the title of
director of the laboratory from 1943
until October 1945 just months after the
bombs were dropped on Japan the site was
home to the Trinity test where
Oppenheimer and his crew tested a bomb
nicknamed the gadget which was the same
design as the fat man nuclear warhead
that was eventually dropped on Nagasaki
in 1954 Oppenheimer was stripped of his
clearance due to apparent ties to the
Communist Party a black mark he was
cleared of nearly 70 years later by U.S
Secretary of Energy Jennifer granholm
after up-and-coming indie film director
Christopher Nolan achieved success with
his 2000 picture Memento he was thrown
into the running to direct Warner
Brothers next crime Thriller insomnia
afterward Nolan fought to prove his
Worth to the studio directing Batman
Begins following that up with the
prestige and then arguably his most
famous film The Dark Knight even after
Legendary pictures another one of
Nolan's collaborators left Warner
Brothers in favor of Universal Pictures
the filmmaker stuck by the studio that
is until fundamental disagreements about
the film industry changed that in 2020
Nolan fought for a theatrical release
for his spy Thriller tenet which he was
granted along with a 10th anniversary
re-release of inception this made tenet
one of the only feature films released
in theaters during the height of the
covid-19 pandemic so imagine the
filmmaker's surprise when Warner
Brothers announced that their 2021 slate
would be released simultaneously to
theaters and on their HBO Max streaming
service
there's such controversy around her
because they didn't tell anyone it's
it's not the way to do business and uh
it's it's not the best thing for the for
the health of our industry by September
2021 Nolan opted to partner with
Universal Pictures and making
Oppenheimer unceremoniously ending his
nearly 20-year partnership with Warner
Brothers
like any good director Christopher Nolan
knows exactly who he wants to work with
after choosing Universal Pictures over
Warner Brothers to produce his upcoming
feature Nolan recruited frequent
collaborator Killian Murphy to join his
cast after six feature films together
including all three parts of the famed
Dark Knight trilogy Inception and
Dunkirk Nolan finally found the perfect
part for Murphy the actor revealed to
Entertainment Weekly it was one of the
best days of my life I'll always turn up
for Chris no matter what the part is but
secretly it's a dream to play a lead
part after 18 years of working together
it's about time while frequent Nolan
collaborators Michael Kane Christian
Bale and Tom Hardy are all absent from
the cast list of Oppenheimer the
director brought back a few other
familiar faces including Gary Oldman who
played commissioner Jim Gordon in the
three Batman features this time around
old men is playing Harry Truman the 33rd
president of the United States marking
this their fourth collaboration together
Kenneth Brana who starred in Nolan's
last World War II Epic Dunkirk also
reunites with Nolan as do the Dark
Knight trilogy actors Tom conti and
David desmulchin it's no secret that
Christopher Nolan has an exceptional
filmography from strong Indie projects
and short films to big budget
Blockbusters and superhero trilogies
there's a reason why Nolan is one of the
most sought after filmmakers in the
business with success after success both
critically and financially Nolan has yet
to direct a dud while many of Nolan's
pictures feature a fair amount of action
especially movies like the superhero
origin Batman Begins or the Spy Thriller
tenet don't expect any high octane
fighting sequences here though
Oppenheimer is set during World War II
there won't be any battle sequences
rather like the prestige his newest
picture is driven by the characters and
the worlds they live in this isn't the
first time Nolan has highlighted nuclear
warfare in 2012's The Dark Knight Rises
Bane threatens Gotham with a nuclear
warhead he's hidden in the city once
Batman finds the weapon he successfully
flies it across the city out into the
Atlantic Ocean where it detonates safely
over water
having previously helmed superhero
movies spine Thrillers sci-fi mind
benders and multiple historical dramas
it's anyone's guess as to what genre
Nolan might tackle next since 2014's
Interstellar Nolan has released a new
movie every three years Dunkirk came out
in 2017 followed by tenet in 2020 and
now Oppenheimer in 2023 while it's not
an exact science previously there were
only two years apart between Nolan's
features his standard from 2006's The
Prestige to 2012's The Dark Knight Rises
it's possible that Nolan will release
his next film in 2026. to date we know
nothing about what Nolan's next super
secret project might be since nothing
has been officially announced but it's
unlikely the filmmaker doesn't have any
other ideas Brewing back in 2015 it was
announced that Nolan's Memento was
getting the Remake treatment but there's
been no words since regardless Nolan was
never officially involved other than
having directed the original though he
served as an executive producer on Zack
Snyder's Justice League Nolan likely
won't continue producing DC com makes
adaptations either especially after
breaking up with Warner Brothers but
whatever story Nolan decides to
undertake next we can rest assured that
Hill put his own twist on the thrilling
Tale